[Music]
everyone yeah my name is max Gretzky but
I'm also known as the wizard and that's
probably because I really like to talk
and write about some pretty complicated
stuff topics that sometimes the seen as
mysterious and hence the named wizard
and I think today we will be talking
about one of the topics of that kind I'm
going to talk about why angular and
react the top web frameworks that we
have today are so fast basically I will
represent present a few JavaScript
optimization techniques that these
frameworks use to make JavaScript run
fast now I work at a grid this is where
we develop the best data grid in the
world so if you need the data grid we
have a free community version with a lot
of features so definitely give it a try
if you need data grid and I'm also the
founder of angular in depth community so
this is where we write and publish
articles about pretty advanced topics of
angular so we will be talking about
three things today one a morphism beat
fields and bloom filters how many of you
know about monomer fizzing which talks
something okay I think I watched the
talk by Benedict from the last year he
gave a talk here about monomer fizzle so
today I'll give you an overview of what
it is and how it is used in these
frameworks I also talked a little bit
about bit fields and I'll show you how
angular use this data structure known as
bloom filters okay let's start with
monomer phase so I do a lot of reverse
engineering I sit at the computer with
the debugger and go through the sources
of the frameworks and this is the
comments that I found inside angular and
react sources so these are the comments
by technical leads of the frameworks and
they talk about something called hidden
class and internal data structures
called fiber and view notes and they
want to ensure that these internal data
structures share the same hidden class
and that is to make property access
monomorphic so a bunch of words when I
first encounter that I didn't really
know what they were talking about so we
need to clarify today what is hidden
class
what is monomorphic property access why
it's important and also what are these
data structures like fiber and view nose
let's start with data structures so
fiber nodes and view nodes in angular
they are used internally to represent a
template basically so when you define a
component this is the Declaration of a
component in angular right we specify
the elements we want to see in a
template and so angular uses view notes
basically data structures that it
creates that represent a template they
define the metadata that is needed to
render the Dom in it also specifies
which part of the Dom needs to be
updated so something called bindings how
many of you here work with angular
can you show you an okay about 30
percent now the same thing in react and
we are to also define components right
we define a template and react uses
fiber notes this is new react 16 fiber
architecture so it uses fiber nodes to
represent the DOM and how many use react
okay
about 40% so yeah so fiber notes and
view notes are used by these frameworks
to represent the temblor so this is
something in between the declaration of
a component template and the Dom what is
common between these data structures is
that they are used a lot when these
frameworks process changes so imagine
this a function called update node and
it's actually an
sample of a function there are a bunch
of functions similar to this one in both
frameworks and this function takes in a
data structure fiber of you note as the
first parameter and then it reads some
property so what's interesting is that
this kind of functions and the property
axis could easily exceed ten thousand
times so framework reads the property
from this data structure more than ten
thousand times every single time changes
are being processed so it can happen a
few times per second so you can imagine
how many times the framework in
JavaScript needs to have access to the
property and the problem is that for
virtual machines like v8 to be able to
it's a complicated process to figure out
where exactly in memory the value for
the property is stored okay and hence
the virtual machines have some
optimization techniques that they use to
make the process faster but first let me
explain to you because when I was trying
to figure out all that stuff the
question I had why is it complicated why
is it complicated to figure out where
the value is right and the answer is
because of something called shapes or
hidden classes right this is exactly the
hidden class that Sebastian talked in
his comment so every single JavaScript
object that you write in your everyday
code is represented by the JavaScript
object JS object internally inside the
VM and this also the corresponding shape
object so shape defines or describes the
layout which properties the object has
and some metadata for example the offset
where to find the value in memory now
you might think why do we need this
shape right when I put all description
of the properties on the object itself
and the reason it is memory safe so if
we have two objects or 1000 objects
right there's no need to describe the
layout every single time we can describe
the layout only once and then link this
object to the shape that describes the
layout right in this way we only
describe the layout once even though we
have no potential millions objects in
memory but then it creates a problem
what if we want to add an extra property
to an object right so this is the setup
and now we want to extend the object a
we want to introduce the new property W
well we need to introduce new shape we
cannot add the double your property to
the original shape right because it
would mean that the other object the
object B that points to the same shape
has this property which is not true so
we need to introduce the new property
and then the new shape and then we
update links the object now the object D
points to the new shape the same thing
happens if we introduce another property
we create one more shape and so in fact
we end up with something called
transition chains and it means that when
you try to access the property for
example ax the original property on the
a object which now points to the shape
that is at the button on the chain it
needs to go through every single
property upwards until it finds the
shape that describes the property okay
and you can imagine that if you add a
lot of properties in different places
and modify objects shape you will have a
transition shape potentially with
hundreds of transitions and so every
single time when you access the property
virtual machine has to go through all
that process to figure out the shape
that describes the layout and memory
set and retrieve that information so in
line kashin is the technique that
virtual machines particularly v8 use to
make this process faster and the idea is
simple the Cashen is the main word here
so every single javascript function is
represented internally by the object
called closure and this is the object
where virtual machines caches some
information about the function which
objects are used to as parameters to
this function and the other information
and feedback vector this is the cache
this is where a virtual machine will
cache some information so let me give
you an example how it works
so suppose we are calling the function
get X and passing an object with the
acts property virtual machine figure out
the shape for this object right and then
what it can do is that it can cache the
shape of the object and then the
property right because we are getting
access to the acts property and also it
encounters the offset right so the next
time when we execute this function and
pass in an object that has the same
shape the virtual machine can only
compare the shapes and if they match
there's no longer need to figure out the
shape right you can just take the cash
value from the offset and use it to
resolve the value in memory and what it
also does it defines the state of the
function and the state there can be
three types of states monomorphic state
a monomorphic property access
polymorphic and mega morphic and in this
case it's monomorphic because the
function has been called only with one
type of shape so it's Mona and
polymorphic is when function has seen
four types of shapes
up to four times and mega morphic is
when you've been passed in objects of
very very different shapes more than
four types of shapes and it is important
that you pass objects of one shape to a
function so the state remains
monomorphic I am when I was reading
sources of angular I found the comment
by Mishka that said that monomorphic
property access can be up to 100 times
faster than mega morphic so now if you
take into account these 10,000 times of
access during each change detection
cycle that can happen several times per
second you can imagine the kind of
impact monomorphic property access can
have on the speed and so frameworks use
this to create actually what they do
they want to enforce that this function
that takes these nodes uses the same
shape same hidden class for fiber and
you notes and that makes property access
monomorphic how did they do it
well in JavaScript templates you can
have different type of knows HTML
elements child components text and if
you follow object-oriented programming
principles you would create different
classes for different elements but these
frameworks actually merge everything
into one data structure one class with
all set of fields and they use one tag
field to distinguish between types of
nodes so this is the code from react
framework this is the function that is
executed for every single Dom element so
potentially thousands of times during
each reconciliation cycle you can see
here that they try to distinguish by tag
and then run the correspondent logic
okay so that's more amorphous
now let's talk about bit fields this is
the other thing that both frameworks
heavily use and a bit field is pretty
low level concept those who have
programmed with C++ for example know
this data structure and bit filters
basically just an array of bits zeros
and ones you can define a bit fill today
in JavaScript just type in 0 B prefix in
console and you will get the binary fill
now react uses bit fields to encode side
effects so side effects in react
basically just operations that the
framework needs to do on Dom elements
maybe place an element in the Dom update
text remove element and instead of
having an array of strings for example
that define operations they just assign
places and say that okay the third bid
is the update operation so if the bit is
one I know that I need a update task if
the bit is zero it means that there is
nothing to do here and I found that when
I was debugging react I'm sitting with
the debugger and I'm following the spawn
element the fiber node corresponding the
spawn element and I have just updated
the tax on the spawn element so I'm
trying to figure out what changes will
have so defect AG is this effects filled
in it's a bit field so right after the
render face when react have process
changes the number the value is four and
because it's a bit field its binary so I
converted it into like here it is
actually the decimal but I know it's
binary so I converted it to binary and
got 1 0 0 and if you explore the effect
tax field you can see here that it's a
third bit and it's exactly what I
expected react encoded the update
operation so later for example here when
the function update host the fax is
executed so react will check every
single bit and see what kind of
it need to perform for example update
will update the tax now you might be
looking at that and think to yourself
well why bother right this is okay this
is speed but it's still too low-level
but there are a number of benefits and
advantages that bid fills have over
other types of data structures for
example with bit fills there is no need
to allocate memory for JavaScript
objects in shapes so the virtual machine
can save a lot of space and because
there is no shapes and JavaScript
objects there are no references it means
that the garbage collection is a lot a
lot simpler you know what you need to
figure out the dependency graph and know
which objects are safe to remove with
the bit field it's just one instruction
to processor to clear the contingent
emery and that's it also with bid fields
is a smaller and continuous memory usage
and it also allows for fast access to
check a single bit right it's just one
beat wise operator and that's it so that
is bit fills heavily used by both
angular and Rihanna and the last data
structure I want to talk about it is
bloom filters and it's very interesting
data structure this it is this data
structure is designed to answer one
simple question is element in Assad or
not right well you can use an array of
course and just go over each element
make a comparison and figure out whether
there's an element in the set or not but
it's quite long right you can imagine
that if you have 1 million objects you
need to go through every single one and
it's pretty long well bloom filters
allows you to do that we just want
operation so I'll show you now how to do
that but what's interesting about bloom
filters is that naturally can get two
types of answers yes or no
when you get the answer no it means that
the element is definitely not in the Sun
but when you get the answer yes it's not
actually yes it's maybe the probability
varies and because of that this data
structure is called probabilistic right
there's probability here you might be
looking at that and thinking to yourself
who needs a data structure that doesn't
give you correct answer right well this
data structure is used most often when
you expect the answer no most of the
time and this is exactly the case that
I'll present to you now
but first I'll show you how this data
structure works so each element in the
side is encoded in a bit field one bit
field or a few bit fields you will have
a hashing function that will take a
value and produce some number for
example for John if we run the function
and we get the number two for example if
we use the first letter and the code for
the letter we will just use a binary or
operator to set the second bit and later
we will use the same function to get the
number for John but now we will use the
bitwise or operator to check if the John
is here and you can imagine if the bit
is not sad if it's zero it means that
John is not here now what the problem is
why yes is not guaranteed
the problem is collisions so if we use
the same fashion function and we for
example used only the first letter to
figure out the number with passing john
and jane they have the same first letter
here we have a collision right so we may
end up with the john being in the south
and jane not being in the side but the
hash the function would produce the same
value and we may get wrong wrong result
so where does angel use this it uses
this in a dependency injection system so
the cornerstone of a dependency
injection system is an injector it's a
service a container where you can
configure the dependencies between
services and then the injector is
responsible for instantiate in them and
where is most systems has only single
injector called global injector angular
has a hierarchical dependency injection
so for the hierarchy of components it
creates in injectors for each component
you got an extra injector so you end up
with a hierarchy of injectors and let's
say that the widget manager service is
provided in the top most injector but
the bottom most component requires or
the pants on the widget so angular would
have to go through every single injector
to figure out where exactly is this
service and only when it reaches the
bottom most injector it will be able to
resolve the component and you can
imagine they could it could take quite a
while for example if every single
injector has 10 dependencies 10 services
you would need to go through every
single one of them and do comparison in
which a long time so when angular does
it introduces a bloom filter for every
single injector and with bloom filter as
they show you it's just one operation to
know whether the service is in the set
or not and as I told you again most of
the time the answer is going to be no
right because we don't actually define a
service in multiple injectors so no here
no here no here and the last the topmost
the answer is maybe and if we get the
answer maybe then we can do our actual
comparison and find the service if it's
there so that is bloom filter for you
okay so here's a bunch of articles that
if you're interested in that kind of
low-level details I've written about
reverse engineering because I've reverse
engineered all web frameworks webpack
plunker other tools also written about
change detection in angular and
reconciliation in react so here the
articles for you to check out also if
you want to learn more about this kind
of topics you can follow me on Twitter I
regularly write about some findings that
I pick in these frameworks and I'm also
written about my journey the article you
can also read so I hope that the
knowledge that I've told you today has
awaken to your curiosity to learn more
about this kind of stuff and I want you
to never stop learning and by doing so
you will be able to reach new heights
every day because I want you all guys to
be extraordinary engineers thank you for
attention and good luck
[Applause]
[Music]